hello my name is Colin Hanks and I feel
excited
about being Conan O'Brien's friend well
wait a minute was it is someone got a
gun to your head what is that I'm just
I'm asking myself out loud yeah you know
what you're doing you're trying it on to
see if it works and turns out these
pants fit
you look fantastic in those I like Conan
pants I got a lot of room where I need
it that's good
you and I and I'm not special because of
this but you and I have always gotten
along very well yeah the first time I
met you I said to myself I like the cut
of this man's jib
um a phrase you don't hear all the time
no and um and but then I realized oh you
probably just get that a lot you're just
uh you're a very lovely guy or talented
fellow so so I'm not in some special
club for liking me some Colin Hanks no
but I will say that you were always very
kind to me because when we actually
first met I was just a super fan of your
show and had gone to tapings and I mean
I remember seeing you at the old late
night show when you came out to LA I
remember oh you came to one of those
when we traveled when you traveled to
L.A uh I remember meeting you then uh
and you were incredibly kind and
gracious and and nice when you really
truly did not have to be I didn't want
to be I know it was it was everything I
could do because that's my gig that's
not yours
and then when I was in college I really
sort of took it as like a I felt like I
had made it because I had been on your
program before Andy left for the first
time I don't know he left seven times
he's left seven times yeah he always
says I'm out and we always have a giant
salute to him and then he comes back but
it was it was such like a point of Pride
like I really did feel like oh wow I'm
officially like part of this you know
thing show business whatever you want to
call it
um and so I think it's always just been
a little bit of a mutual admirations
yeah we uh we get along really fine I'll
say that real real fine
um but uh it's a really weird way to say
that I don't think so I think I think
what I'm talking to Colin I I slip into
a certain vernacular that he and I
understand he's saying a cut of his jib
and it's fine like a nice real fine yeah
really really fine yeah yeah it's just
weird are you sure you guys aren't just
close and he's not just a translator for
you
I think that's probably it could be it
could be uh I remember
um
and we were bringing this up I was
walking along the beach one day as I do
it sounds like the beginning of a song
yeah I was walking along the beach one
day and uh and I saw you and I was so
excited because you had just been in the
show Fargo yes and I've loved it I was
wary because I thought this is one of my
favorite movies how is this going to be
a TV show and so I went on for about 15
minutes about how thrilled I was that
you were in Fargo how great you were I
loved your character and I was looking
forward to more and you broke the news
to me on the beach that no it it all
changes up after every year and I swear
to God I was devastated because I I
really got I don't know if other people
have had this with Fargo I'm sure they
have I've really liked different seasons
but I really liked that season and
thought Oh great I'm I'm on this journey
and I'm gonna see Colin and these other
terrific actors go forward yeah and then
they Shuffle the deck and I was I was
frankly enraged there was uh well there
was a brilliant lesson in Show Business
is that I had waited I think seven years
to like try and find like a program that
was like as as good as my hopes were
yeah and in that time they they created
uh shows that only exist for one season
I know
but you know there was that era of Show
Business uh which which you and I know
uh Colin I'm sure much older than you
but we both remember that air of show
business where you get a on a show and
it clicks and Everyone likes it
you're all set for seven years yeah and
then just at some point in the not not
too long ago they uh they changed it up
so it's like did you like that I really
liked it good it's gone
because the streaming model and you're
like wait a minute wait a minute what
are you talking about can't we have more
of those and yet the the the argument uh
can easily be made that that's what
makes those you know those Seasons so
good because there's a a definite
beginning middle and an end right uh
that's how I like my storytelling that's
not how I like my jobs
but that's how I like my storytelling
no I like my jobs it goes and goes and
goes you're all middle man I'm all
middle I don't like a beginning I just
like my career pretty much has been I
got started in 1985 went right to the
middle and have stayed there yeah and
just found different parts of the middle
yeah and they and people keep suggesting
you could probably move on now you're
over 80 to the to the later part like to
the part where the Bears find Goldilocks
uh and I'm like no no I like the part
where I'm still trying out the beds I
mean I think that's actually really one
of the cool things about like your
journey for lack of a better phrase is
that you've always seemed to be the one
that goes towards the area that that
tickles you the most yes that keeps you
as engaged as possible and very selfish
well but I just like to be happy well
but to be honest like that actually
makes everything else
it makes all the other components of
Show Business worthwhile you know if
you're not trust me if you're not
digging it it is a drag to you know for
everybody else and that is I think one
of the reasons why I think it's so
fantastic that you've like created this
space yeah because I thought like oh man
I'm coming and I'm going to see Conan
and it's going to be Gourley and like
four other people and that's it and it's
gonna I don't know what the space is
gonna be like this is a happening I mean
you created a a fun house here yeah the
model was uh Hugh Hefner's Chicago home
his townhouse which explains your outfit
in 1965. it explains your outfit I am
wearing a beautiful robe right now
you know people tell me that it was uh
it's not the right era anymore and I
don't see any evidence of that no not in
the style land and your misogyny it's
all still there no we found this space
which we talk about from time to time
but we found this space in Larchmont
which is this really nice cool happening
area of LA and uh and we built our
little I I wanted a Pee-wee's Playhouse
I wanted a bat cave yeah a place where I
think of this more as your little like
Subterranean Silence of the Lambs well
you know well you just sort of a dark
place well it's a dark room there are
you have been outside
and and also that explains why I haven't
seen you and so be fair to Gorly there
are fingernails embedded in the wall
yeah mine
um you keep putting lotion on nobody
knows why I'm waiting for the basket to
come down I never asked you to put on
lotion that was your idea just give me a
biscuit this is a this is a version of
seven to the Lambs where gorley's at the
bottom of the well and he keeps asking
for more lotion and the serial killer is
like what wait wait what I put the
lotion in the basket
you've never looked better in a kimono
though it's I think it's very important
to say you should see me out of it
you're in the kimono